PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, it turns out
that switching to
microservices is not
that easy without a
plan and a process,
so you need to keep watching to
learn more about the migration
process.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: The
microservices-based
architecture is beneficial
due to its loosely coupled
components that can
be independently
tested and deployed.
In theory, the smaller and
simpler a component is,
the easier it is to
maintain and deploy.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
each independent service
can be implemented in different
languages and frameworks
so you can use the right tool
for the particular job you're
trying to do.
CARTER MORGAN:
Each component can
be managed by a
different team, reducing
dependencies between teams.
This clear boundary
between services
allows a team to more
easily design for failure,
and it becomes
easier determine what
to do if a service is down.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
But does this mean
microservices are as perfect
as a homemade souffle?
Well, no.
You see, with
monolithic platforms,
every logical component can
speak to every other component
pretty much by default
because they're
all part of the same whole.
But with microservices,
even though
each individual component is
simpler and easier to manage,
how those services work together
to communicate and to behave
as a system is more complicated
and possibly slower due
to the added network latency.
CARTER MORGAN: Still,
many, including Google,
has been doing this
for many years.
Many believe that
microservices are a big win
overall for most organizations.
But if you don't design your
microservices correctly,
you may end up with a
distributed monolith.
And that's even worse
than the monolith
you had in the first place.
It can take months
to actually migrate.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So we definitely know
it's not going to be simple.
But to help simplify
that process--
and because with
any recipe, it's
important to know what the end
result is going to look like--
let's map the path from
a monolithic, on-premise
application to an
application that's
fully hosted on
Google Cloud Platform
and built with microservices.
CARTER MORGAN: If
you have already
migrated your
monolithic application
as is into the cloud, then
the same steps we discuss here
can be applied to create
microservices architecture.
For most e-commerce
platforms, the starting point
is a monolithic
application on premises.
Your platform will probably
have load balancers to handle
incoming requests from the web.
These requests will be routed
to your application servers.
These application servers are
responsible for processing
the requests by utilizing
components like cache,
database, search, et cetera.
Additionally, your app
servers may send requests
to other back-end systems.
Obviously, this can't
be fully representative
of your current
system, but it should
serve as an example
that's similar in theory
to yours so you can migrate
it towards our target
architecture.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Now let's talk
about the end state, what
we are trying to achieve.
We definitely want to achieve
the same functionality,
as Carter mentioned,
in the monolith,
except now, instead
of running a monolith,
we would break that up into
individual microservices
running in portable,
deployable units of code called
containers, using
Google Kubernetes
Engine, a platform
that handles scaling,
hosting, and
deploying containers.
In this architecture,
each microservice
runs in its own
containers and makes
call to the back-end system
through a secure network
connection.
We are still routing internet
traffic through a load
balancer, but now
the traffic is routed
into separate microservices.
This lets us update version
of individual microservices
while only minimally
affecting the other services.
And in our target
architecture, the microservices
may interact with a number
of other GCP products.
Cloud Storage, Cloud
SQL, and Cloud Pub/Sub
are common GCP products for
e-commerce applications.
So Carter, how do
we make this happen?
CARTER MORGAN: One of the
most important decisions
you must make early
during this migration
is how to handle communication
between the new microservices
hosted on GKE and your
legacy system on premises.
Since we're migrating
in stages, there
will be large
periods of time where
components of your platform
will be living in both GKE
and on premises.
Now, there are two
main solutions,
and they can co-exist--
API-based communication
or communication
based on a private
network connection.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: In
the API-based solution,
you use an API management
solution, such as Apigee,
as a proxy between
the two environments.
This gives you a precise
control over what portions
of your legacy system you
expose and how you expose them.
It also lets you
seamlessly refactor
the implementation of an API--
that is, moving from a legacy
service to a microservice--
without impacting the
consumers of the API.
CARTER MORGAN: In a solution
based on private connectivity,
you connect your GCP and
on-premise environments
using a private
network connection.
The microservices communicate
with your legacy system
over this connection.
You can set up IPsec-based
VPN tunnels with Cloud VPN.
For larger bandwidth,
high availability,
and low latency needs,
Cloud Interconnect
is a better option.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now
let's compare and contrast
the two communication options.
Compared to private
connectivity,
an API-based solution is
implemented by the application
teams and requires a greater
integration with the legacy
application from the get go,
so it is harder to set up
but provides more management
options in the long run.
On the other hand,
a solution based
on Cloud VPN or
Cloud Interconnect
will be implemented
by a networking team
and initially requires less
integration with the legacy
application, but it does
not provide any added
value in the long term.
CARTER MORGAN: Now that we know
more about these communication
options, we can combine
the two approaches
and use them to our benefit.
For example, we
can use Apigee only
for the public APIs in front
of the microservice and legacy
systems but not between
them, and Cloud VPN or cloud
internet for the communication
between the microservice
and legacy systems.
This option combines the
benefits of the two approaches
but is more complex to manage.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: One
of the other choices
we have to make
when migrating is
which GCP technologies to use.
For example, do you want to use
Cloud Bigtable to store data,
or do you want to
keep using some
of your current technologies
because they're still
relevant to you or because
the cost of moving them
is too high?
You should think
about these choices
as a part of the
migration process.
CARTER MORGAN: Here's the point.
This is a complex process
that won't happen overnight.
So any planning
you do beforehand,
like how will my
services communicate,
how will I manage data, what
should I migrate first--
any of this goes to help make
sure the process goes smoothly.
For more information about
alternative migration
approaches, check
out the article
written by Marco [INAUDIBLE].
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, there you have it.
If you are in the process
of migrating a monolith
to microservices, then you got
a small taste of the process
here.
Stay tuned for the
next episode, where
we will be discussing
the migration in stages.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]